Next, we're going to get some
practice tracing through Turing
machine computations and
programming Turing machines.
The point of these exercises is not so
that you can put on your resume
that you're good at
programming Turing machines.
And if someone asks you in an interview
to write a program to test, say,
whether an input number is prime,
I wouldn't recommend trying to draw
a Turing machine stake diagram.
Somehow, I doubt that
will land you the job.
Rather, the point is to
help you convince yourself
that Turing machines can do everything
that we mean by computation.
And if you really had to, you could
program a Turing machine to do anything
you could write a procedure to do in
your favorite programming language.
There are two ways to
convince yourself of this.
One is to just practice so
that you build up enough of a facility
with programming Turing machines.
That is to say,
it just becomes easy enough for you, so
that it seems intuitive
that you could do anything.
Another way to convince yourself
of the power of Turing machines
is to show that a Turing
machine can simulate the action
of models that are closer to real world
computers, like the random access model.
We'll do that in a later lesson.
But to be able to understand
these simulation arguments,
you need a pretty good facility with
how Turing machines work anyway.
So make the most of these examples and
exercises.